problema número 201 si la suma de n
enteros consecutivos es 0 cuál de los
siguientes enunciados es verdadero 1 en
el espacio 2 n es impar 3 el promedio es
ser así que nos piden la suma de enteros
consecutivos pues para que la suma sea 0
algunos tendrán que ser negativos pues
para compensar a los positivos
visualicemos esto con una recta numérica
así más o menos tenemos aquí a nuestro
entero ser y debemos tener aquí algunos
números de este lado y otros de este
lado para que el resultado sea a 0
imaginemos que tengo aquí mi número a
todavía no sé cuál es para que la suma
sea 0 debo de tener aquí menos a como
parte de este conjunto para que menos a
massa me deseó qué pasa si n es igual a
1 o sea sólo tengo un dígito pues para
que sea 0 ese dígito tendría que ser
cero o sea n si podría ser igual a 1
siempre y cuando ese dígito sea cero qué
pasa si en es igual a 2 pues tendría yo
dos números tendría cero ese no lo puedo
quitar
y mi otro número no se podría ser por
ejemplo 100 más 1 no me da hacer me da
uno tendría por fuerza yo que tener aquí
desde otro lado a menos uno para que la
suma de estos tres merecer entonces en
él no puede ser igual a dos debe tener
más números si n es igual a tres pues ya
vimos que esto si funciona si fuera n
igual a 4 pues igual tendré yo aquí otro
número pero ya tendría otros tres que no
me dejarían la suma igual a cero
entonces de todo esto yo lo que intuyo
es que n no es para n no puede ser para
no puede ser ya que siempre tenemos que
tener al cero como parte de los docentes
o si necesitamos otros dos pues para que
se compense el negativo con el positivo
y el resultado sea cero veamos las
opciones n es par no vimos que esto no
puede ser
es impar ah pues si vivimos en él no
puede ser paz n ese impase el promedio
es cero
recordemos que es el promedio es la suma
de todas las cantidades entre el número
de cantidades que son pero como la suma
de esto desde un principio estamos
buscando que sea cero pues algo en 30
siempre y cuando tenga más de un número
para dividir el promedio va a ser cero
así que ésta también se cumple por lo
que el inciso que me pone que el número
dos y el número tres son verdaderos es
el inciso e muy bien siguiente problema
problema número 202 en la fórmula b
igual a uno entre dos por r al cubo
cierre se reduce a la mitad cuántas
veces se multiplica b para mí lo más
sencillo es ponerle números a la fórmula
por ejemplo calcular esta fórmula cuando
eres igual a 2 cuando desees igualados y
después calcular la misma fórmula cuando
eres igual a 1 y así pues ver que le
pasa a b
hagamos aquello si tuvimos r igualados
va a ser igual a 1 / 2 por ere 2 por 244
al cubo 4 al cubo es 64 1 entre 64 ahora
qué pasa cuando reciba la 1 veamos b es
igual a 2 por ere 2 por 1 2 2 al cubo es
81 entre 8 pues aquí lo que pasó es que
b fue multiplicado ocho veces si yo
multiplico esto por ocho me va a dar 8
entre 64 que si lo simplificó va a ser
igual a un octavo eso es lo que pasa con
fe cuando r se reduce a la mitad se
multiplica por ocho y esta va a ser mi
opción b para mí es más fácil trabajar
con números reales en lugar de estar
trabajando con variables en este tipo de
problemas e incrementar las variables y
bueno para mí se me complica veamos el
siguiente problema problema número 203
cierta empresa tiene seis empleados y
paga salarios anuales de 14 mil a 2
empleados
seis mil a un empleado y 17.000 a tres
empleados restantes cuál de las
siguientes cantidades es más cercana al
sueldo promedio de cada empleado
anotemos los datos a dos empleados les
paga 14000 lo abrevió con 14 k la caja
es de 1000 am un empleado le paga 16 mil
y a tres empleados le paga o les paga 17
mil vamos a encontrar primero el
promedio que va a ser multiplicar cada
una de estas cantidades de suelo por las
personas a los que se los pagan y
dividirlo entre el número de personas
veamos dos por 14 vamos a quitar la cara
para ahorrarnos algunos cálculos 16 más
3 por 17 todo esto entre 6 muy bien 2
por 14 es 28 más 16 más 7 por 321 3
poner a 345 51 entre 6 esto es igual a
28 16 51 va a ser 95 95 entre 6
96-106 es 16 pero aquí en 95 va a ser
menos un poquito menos que 16 pero vamos
a hacer la división para que estamos
inventando verdad aquí 95 entre 6 es
igual aquí a 1 696 estrés bajo el 56 por
530 35 menos 30 me queda 5 y como se
hablando de miles voy a hacer esta
división un poquito más extensa pongo el
punto decimal aquí bajo un 0 y
multiplicó por 8 6 por 8 48 50 menos 48
es igual a 2 otro 0 acá 6 por 3 18 y el
resultado de 20 menos 18 es 2 bueno
entonces es 15.83 que quedamos que
hablábamos de miles así que esto es
igual a 15 mil 830 aproximadamente y
bien a mis opciones la cantidad más
cercana es 15 mil 800 que es la opción c
siguiente problema problema número 204
si x es igual a la suma de los enteros
pares entre 40 y 60 incluyendo los que
es el número de enteros pares entre 40 y
60 incluyendo los también cuál es el
valor de x más encontrar que es bastante
fácil y es el número de enteros pares
entre 40 y 60 pues vamos a escribirlos y
vamos a ubicarnos 40 es par 42 es par 44
46 48 50 52 54 56
58 y 60 porque aquí tenemos todos los
números pares entre 40 y 60 incluyendo
los contemos cuántos son 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 son 11 números por lo que mire
es igual a 11 ahora la suma de todos
estos que es el valor de x es así está
un poquito más complicada no me voy a
poner a sumar todas estas cantidades
directamente porque me va a llevar más
tiempo y acuérdense que aquí cuando
estamos en exámenes el tiempo es vital
hay que hacer las cosas rápido y bien yo
sé que esto es igual a tener 40 más 0 42
44 46 y 48 hasta aquí todo esto es lo
mismo que lo que tengo acá pero me
permite ubicar que tengo este 40
repetidos 5 veces por lo que puedo hacer
la operación de 40 x
y a estos sumarles pues las unidades 0 2
4 6 8 6 4 es 10 + 8 18 más 220 esto es
más 20 5 por 4 20 el 0 que tenemos nos
hace un 200 más 20 esto es igual a 220
que nada más es la parte del 40 ahora
hagamos lo mismo pero aquí en la parte
del 50/50 es igual a 50 0 53 es igual a
50 más 250 más 450 más 650 más 8 y 50
más 10 aquí tenemos un número más puede
tener 550 es tenemos uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis va a ser 50 por 6 más la suma
de 2 más 4 y 6 6 12 más 18 es 20 más 10
es 30
ahora 6 x 5 30 esto es 330 igual a 330
pero todavía no hemos terminado tenemos
que sumar estas cantidades para
encontrar x x es igual a 220 más 330 va
a ser igual a 550 y ahora si ya tenemos
x
y si los sumamos recordamos que ya
encontramos que era igual a 11 hacemos
la suma va a ser 561 x + ya que es mi
opción de nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo